hey guys today we're going to try
something a bit different I'm going to
walk you through a full functional
workout routine so that you can see how
you might apply some of the concepts we
talk about on this channel to your own
training I'm going to blabber through
the whole thing to provide tips
observations commentary Etc this is a
full body routine that will build
strength add size in those aesthetic
areas but also greatly increase
functional performance that means
preparing the body for more
unpredictable angles it means increasing
strength endurance so that that you
don't become exhausted it means training
in those overlooked planes of motion
frontal and rotational it means training
muscles that get overlooked too such as
the rumb boids forearms and obliques and
it means focusing on real useful
athletic abilities like sprinting
balancing and jumping I want to
demonstrate that you can achieve all of
that in a single routine while still
providing plenty of stimulus for growth
and adaptation I want to show that
functional training in this way is fun
extremely useful and very different from
although not not Superior to other forms
of training like bodybuilding and
powerlifting if you're a cynic when it
comes to the phrase functional training
then I ask you to watch this through and
then tell me what you would call it and
to honestly say this isn't a cool way to
train this program is designed to do all
of that in a single routine addressing
the entire body I also aim to keep the
routine shorsh and manageable and to not
use any equipment except the jump rape
you're seeing here and that can be
substituted for a ton of other stuff
Shadow Boxing skater hops High star
jumps you can even do jump rope without
the
rope that said I always think you should
view the warmup as part of the workout
so to get started I'm choosing jump rope
as it has a bunch of unique benefits not
only is it going to get the heart rate
elevated and get the blood flowing where
we want it but it's also great for
developing timing and coordination it's
also really good for developing ankle
stiffness stiffening those tendons so
that we can deliver more power to the
ground when sprinting and jumping stiff
tendons doesn't mean you're immobile
stiff tendons are a very good thing just
ask J Santana who notes how he transfer
forwards momentum into the ground via
tendons When jumping from a run it's not
about muscle strength you barely bend
your knees in this scenario it's about
rebound jump rope can be a little bit
harsh on the joints if you're not
careful so do make sure you have a soft
surface like this one and make sure you
aren't jumping too high as you jump over
the Rope tiny little hops are fine
here
addressing my own form for a moment I'd
say that my arms are outstretched a
little bit too far my elbows should be
tucked in more but this is partly due to
the Rope being just a tad too long for
me I should have asked for a smaller
size I've come to realize to be clear
I'm not particularly great at jump rope
at all I don't need to be to get the
benefits though and what's great is that
I've been improving steadily just by
regularly using this in my warm-ups so
you'll see here that I go for the full 3
minutes only needing to rest start a
couple of times something that wouldn't
have been the case a year or so ago
Grant has a whole tutorial on jumping
rope on this channel I recommend
checking that out if you want to learn
more he's way better than me I'm doing 3
minutes of jump rape which is more than
long enough to get the benefits we want
to get the blood flowing to get the
heart rate up
[Music]
Etc
okay moving on now to some active
stretches the aim here is to improve
mobility and thus help me move better
through the actual workout each position
is held or explored for a minute total
these are active stretches meaning that
I'm not passively relaxing all the way
into the stretch or using external
assistance to force myself into the
deepest positions instead I'm
maintaining strength and luring myself
into place or bobbing myself up and down
in position undulating and exploring the
position specifically this is the type
of stretching I recently addressed in my
video on the liquid motion system I
hadn't much luck with the static
stretches but I found that moving around
at the end range of motion and just
getting used to moving in those places
being able to move in those places has
made a huge difference I remain relaxed
but I keep it as a strength exercise for
example in the Deep squat position here
I'm moving gently up and down around my
sticking point of course getting into a
deep squat like this is perfect for
improving my ility for the subsequent
movements we're going to be doing like
the pistol squat the resting squat is a
position that should feel like a
relaxing and natural position to get
into and yet it's one that a lot of
people can't hold without falling over
or experiencing significant discomfort
this is something we should be aiming to
address in pretty much any functional
training routine this does also mean
we're getting a slight strength training
benefit and this is where something like
the CAC squat where I'm moving down to
each side is so beneficial I'm getting a
little frontal plane motion here and
strengthen the hips not in a big way but
just a little
way at this point I'd like to highlight
the shoes I'm wearing these are Hydra
esc's from Vivo Barefoot today's
sponsors I've been wearing barefoot
shoes for over 4 years now almost
exclusively and honestly I'm not sure I
could go back to doing this kind of
training without them why because
minimal shoes like these provide you
with a wider toe box allowing the feet
to spay and giving you more surface area
for balancing and running you have a
smaller Heel To Toe drop meaning you
aren't forced up on your heels in a
position of permanent plantar flexion
that lack of a big heel comes in
extremely handy for movements like this
where I'm testing my Mobility if your
heel is elevated off the floor then you
won't be getting as much of a stretch in
the bottom of the squat say you'll be
constantly moving in a shortened range
of motion in my opinion if you can't
deep squat Barefoot you can't really
deep Squat and another benefit of these
shoes of course is that you have far
greater proception and ability to feel
the ground underneath your feet later in
this workout we'll be doing sprints and
you'll see that this is absolutely
crucial at this point traditional shoes
pretty much invite a twisted ankle
otherwise via Barefoot make my favorite
minimal shoes these shoes in particular
are ideal for trail running but I love
them for functional training in general
they dry out quickly so I'm good to get
them wet they have amazing grip for
sprinting and I think they look pretty
badass all of via barefoot shoes are
comfortable and beautifully made and
they have a very wide selection if
you're interested you can get 15% off
your purchase by using Code the bioner
15 at checkout use the link in the
description down below to find out
[Music]
more likewise these really deep lunges
are not only great for stretching out
the hip flexors an area that is tight in
nearly anyone who works a desk job but
they're also amazing for strengthening
the knee all knees over toes
guy once again I'm just moving around in
the area and keeping the muscles
engaged you may have heard that
stretching before workout can actually
increase the chance of injury as you
lose some of the tension and muscle tone
while the is true that refers primarily
to passive stretches as opposed to this
kind of active stretching and the
opposite actually seems to be true for
Mobility work that involves a strength
element like this and it's also worth
noting that we should take this with a
pinch of salt not because it's not true
but because it's a very marginal
increased risk that is also highly
dependent on the type of stretch and the
nature of the training athletes were
stretching before their workouts and
competitions for decades before this
research came out so don't fret too much
it seems sometimes like every every time
a new study comes out everyone
completely changes their training throws
the baby out with the bath water not
that this is at all new at this
point likewise I'll be doing one-legged
good mornings to develop the hip hinge
and make sure that I'm moving through
the hip hinge properly when I'm doing
leg exercises later on if you have a
lightweight like a kettle bell hanging
around maybe 10 kg you can use this to
make the movement a little bit more
challenging training the hip hinge is
one of the trickier challenges of body
weight only
training so to perform the single-legged
body weight good morning basically what
you're going to do you're going to kick
one leg slightly back behind you to use
as a kickstand and the other one's going
to keep nice and straight and that's the
one where we're going to be stretching
the hamstring and at the same time we're
practicing that hip hinge movement so
focus on moving your buttcks backwards
rather than bending at the lower
spine okay so now I'm moving to to a
different spot to work on the shoulders
we're starting with some shoulder
openers whereby I'll be using a tree to
get a good overhead stretch for the lats
and then out to the side for the pecs
this will improve shoulder Mobility
which is great for posture and for
pulling off moves like handstands and
Pike push-ups and we're going to be
doing Pike push-ups later which makes
this a pretty good
choice make sure that you feel the
stretch in the Target area while you do
this whether that's the PEC or the lats
it's on you to make that mind muscle
connection if you want the stretch to
actually work
properly you should feel this in the
lats and the pecs respectively and again
I'm moving through this position and I'm
pushing a little bit and I'm trying to
lift off the arm not just staying in one
position I'm training at a nature
reserve today to demonstrate that you
need no stuff at all to get a functional
workout in you can do it literally
anywhere this isn't a fundamental
requirement you can do the the same
workout in a gym or pretty much anywhere
else but you do get some added benefits
from training this way as we'll
see and now I'm moving into a dead hang
I've made a whole video on hangs this
means we're literally just hanging from
the branch or bar and that's going to
get us even more of a Peck and L stretch
open up the shoulder some more
decompress the spine and even train the
grip as a nice added benefit I'm holding
this for about a minute which isn't too
much of a challenge for
me found a sweet spot with an rpe of
about 6 or seven I'll be using this term
that means rate of perceived exertion
it's scored out of 10 so in this case
we're using 60 to 70% of maximum effort
as a dead hang this means you're
completely relaxing the body other than
the grip of course it would fall off
that means your shoulders should be up
by your ears with no tension at all if
possible my feet are lightly touching
the ground you'll notice they're not
taking any weight off the arms but what
they are doing is allowing my core to
relax even more helping me to get more
spinal decompression that was roughly a
12 minute warm-up for a roughly 35 to 40
minute workout total which isn't a too
bad ratio but that said if you wanted
more mobility and more posture benefits
I add in a crab
reach so the first exercise is the swan
pull this is a movement from gymnastics
training and it's a bit of an unusual
one I might give it its own video in
future while still holding the bar or
Branch you're going to pull your body up
but using only your scapular AKA
shoulder blades start from the same dead
hang position and then depress the
shoulder blades moving them down and
retract them pulling them back we want
to pack the scapula here you should find
that your upper body arches so that your
sternum is now pointing up at the sky
and so are your nipples there are a few
ways to do this movement for example
some people then perform an arched
pull-up however we're just going to hold
for a moment squeezing those shoulder
blades and then lower back to the
starting position for a single rep my
arms Bend slightly here but that's not
the aim at all it's just okay if that
happens not only is this a great
precursor to tougher movements like the
front lever but it's also amazing for
your posture by training the scapula
retractors you'll be counteracting that
hunched fors position position that so
many of us experience you can feel this
benefit almost as soon as you come down
from the bar your shoulders will be back
and your chest puffed out like a
superhero of course this is also a great
move for stronger lats and is excellent
for training the horizontal pull pattern
for a more detailed description I highly
recommend the channel mover Odyssey
which has a great breakdown the video is
called the perfect hang that YouTube
channel is just a treasure Trove of
amazing information I'm doing six reps
of these for two sets total if this
movement is too too hard try using body
weight rows instead if it's too easy try
doing more reps of an arched back pullup
bringing the sternum all the way to
touch the bar rest between sets for 30
to 90 seconds this goes for all
exercises 30 seconds if you want a more
hypertrophy focus and you don't mind
failing to complete your final set 90
seconds if you're more interested in
strength control and
performance I'm actually going to cut
out all of my rest times in this video
partly because that would make for a
pretty dull video to watch and this
whole full workout thing is an
experiment to begin with and partly
that's because my rests were actually
all over the place because I had to set
up all the cameras and move around with
them next is a leg exercise the elevated
pistol squat so go and find a bench or a
low wall or a step now you're going to
stand on it with one foot dangle the
other foot over the edge and then lower
yourself into the deepest squat position
possible before pushing yourself back up
again training without equipment makes
it tricky to get enough of a stimulus
for certain areas to grow legs being key
culprits this is why calisthenics
athletes famously have relatively slim
legs but this movement shows that most
people should still be able to get
plenty of stimulus training without
weight you just have to be a bit more
creative not only is this a very
challenging squat that will really hit
the glutes and build a ton of strength
it's also great for training balance and
Mobility these barefoot shoes mean we
get really deep here getting a really
nice stretch on the glutes and really
encouraging growth and by training
single leg strength we improve
athleticism and address imbalances I'm
mixing up the exercises here rather than
focusing on each body part to ensure we
get maximum recovery time we've got some
more brutal leg training coming up and
training it back to back would make
things very challenging you might even
be feeling a little bit sore from some
of the mobility stuff if this is new to
you of course you're welcome to hold on
to something if the balance challenge is
a bit too much try to keep your back as
straight as you can as much as possible
I'm getting a little bit of buttwink
towards the end of the second set as I'm
needing to use more momentum to get
through the movement and my form has got
a little bit sloppy buttwink isn't the
end of the world especially without
weight on your back and for some people
it's going to be an unavoidable result
of their Anatomy but it's better to
reduce it as much as you're able to and
you can see here that as form breaks
down it does start coming back if these
are too hard for you you can do body
weight Bulgarian split squats or just
lunges if they're too easy do full
pistol squats or maybe grab a log to
hold aim for an eight rpe I did two sets
of
eight by the way guys if you are
enjoying this type of training then you
might also enjoy my ebook and full
training program super functional
training 2.0 while this is a single
workout designed to work with no
equipment in a short amount of time that
program is a much more detailed routine
that works with a variety of equipment
or very little adapts to any level and
is far more comprehensive in scope for
those that want to maximize their
performance it's made from exercises
like these ones but many many more and
it comes with over 2 hours of
instructional video and an 85 Plus page
ebook and if you order quickly you can
benefit from a massive black Friday week
discount it's just $12 at the moment
I'll put the link down
below now we're moving on to chin-ups
the aim here is to give the lats a
little bit more love while
simultaneously targeting the biceps now
this is where you will get a whole bunch
of bonus credit if you are training
outside like me I've talked in the past
about the huge benefits of training on
tree branches every tree branch is at a
slightly different angle has slightly
different thicknesses and is slightly
different at different points so one
hand might be on a thicker bit and one
hand might be on a thinner bit the
result is that I'm using a slightly
different combination of muscles every
single rep or at least every single set
this is what I refer to as chaos
training and it transfers better to real
world activities like rock climbing
because you're not just pulling in the
same precise linear motion You're
Building more robust movement patterns
to quote Nikolai burn Stein and more
adaptable
fascia but what really benefits is the
grip guys pick a thick branch like this
one and you will feel this in your hands
a big time and it translates to Greater
bicep work too you get a crazy bicep
pump you know this train in nature this
chaos training thing might sound like a
gimmick to some sure you say maybe doing
a pull-up from a branch is technically
slightly harder but you can't progress
it in the same way it's just going to
mean you learn the pull-up lower but no
I mean it try it and you will rapidly
feel the difference now tell me that
that won't transfer to Superior
performance that said if you do want to
do this workout in the gym then using a
pull-up bar will work just fine I mean I
guess if this is too hard try performing
the movement assisted with a lower
Branch keeping your feet on the ground
aim for an 8 RP I did two sets of eight
for reference I can do about 25 chinups
on a regular bar in one set
now we're doing squats these are
serious business for your legs only this
time we're primarily targeting the quads
the squat is a squat performed on
the balls of the feet where you lean
your torso backwards and push your knees
forwards this massively isolates the
quads and creates a lot of tension
making it one of the very best ways to
develop quads for both appearance and
performance the Cissy squat is an
advanced move make no mistake this is
not for those with knee problems if you
have healthy knes it will make them even
stronger as long as you build up to it
gradually start with a low low rep range
and a small range of motion and build up
you can even start with an easier
movement called the Hindu squat I made a
whole video about this one or you can do
an assisted squat holding onto a
bench or something and helping yourself
through the movement with your arms even
if you're not using the bench as an
assist though I recommend using it for
balance whilst you pump out reps this
shouldn't really be used as a balanced
challenge not only because that can lead
to a nasty the accident if you do fall
over but also because the lack of
stability in this movement will mean you
can't optimally fatigue the target
muscles you need to support yourself if
you're training for strength this way
you can use it for all its strength and
size building potential and better
isolate the target muscles if you need a
harder variation then you can try
one-legged squats but at this
point I don't even know who you are now
aim for a seven or an eight rpe I did
two sets of
eight now we're moving on on to the pike
push-up the pike push-up is a push-up
with the buttcks elevated like you're my
daughter expecting me to clean her butt
and check for a threadworm starting in
an almost downward dog position and then
letting the upper body move diagonally
downwards to Target the shoulders more
than a regular push-up W try to keep the
forearm straight As you lower yourself
forming a triangle as your head moves
just in front of them try to keep the
Torso as straight as you can hinging at
the hips and push through the shoulder
blades at the top of the movement
working the traps this is an excellent
exercise for targeting the shoulders
that as we can see also gives you some
trap development it's also great if
you're learning to handstand the pike
push-up is an easy one to progress just
elevate your legs Higher and Higher and
eventually you can transition to a full
wall assisted handstand push-up the same
goes for all these exercises by the way
if you're wondering how to progress you
progress by moving onto harder
variations this should be a lower 7 to8
RP I did two sets of eight you might be
wondering why only doing two sets of
each exercise the answer is that I'm
trying to create the most efficient
workout possible while some studies show
that three sets are best for growth the
truth is you don't always need them not
if our primary interest is in functional
performance not if we train with enough
intensity as we see with high-intensity
training and enough we're hitting the
same area with different moves
subsequently now it's time for the
lizard crawl this is an exercise I've
recently featured in some other videos
it is one of the most bang for your buck
movements out there it's also fun even
if it makes you look a little crazy
essentially it's a crawl as you can see
but you're letting your chest get very
close to the ground by moving your arms
and legs out more to the side and
bending them more the arms are bent at
the elbows like an alligator and your
legs come up to the side of your body
giving you some more great hip training
and frontal plane movement I'd like to
take this opportunity to apologize for
any shots here that are out of focus
filming such a long movement is tricky
especially when your Osmos pocket thr
refuses to follow your movement to be
fair it's actually a brilliant little
device that I really love but it's
programmed to track humans not whatever
I look like here this would be another
reason I don't often do this kind of
video let me know if you like this
though guys I can certainly do more like
it in future I had fun
actually it's a contralateral movement
this one meaning that the arms and legs
are moving on opposite sides of the body
as they do when you walk or run and this
makes it great for developing more
coordination we're going to be rotating
the core to get the leg up nice and high
on the other side and that means that
it's a much needed movement for the
rotational plane you'll also feel it in
the glutes and quads a bit as you push
off your feet especially if you're going
uphill primarily though this is an
exercise for the pecs shoulders triceps
and core you should be able to feel a
really good stretch on the pecs at the
bottom of each rep really let yourself
sink into
that once again this is a movement that
is slightly different every single time
you perform it making it ideal as a form
of chaos training for preparing your
body for actual activity outside of the
gym if you'd like to learn more about
chaos training then check out my recent
print book adaptive training again being
outside massively increases the
challenge here I had to contend with
going up a slight incline it's also a
great example of strength endurance and
you can progress the exercise with time
speed or technique I did two sets of one
minute if this movement is too difficult
for you then some Alternatives include
push-ups one-armed push-ups or regular
be
craws and finally I'm ending this
workout with a high-intensity cardio
finisher that being Sprints or Sprint
intervals I just picked two trees that
are good distance apart I haven't
measured them or anything I'm going to
Sprint to one and then walk back and
then repeat for a total of five sets
sprinting is an incredible exercise that
does you a ton of good it's explosive of
course and it develops lots of fast TCH
fiber you're also training pretty much
every muscle in the legs including the
calves tibialis anterior glutes
hamstrings quads Etc the jump rate we
did earlier is also great for the cares
by the way it's also great for peaking
growth hormone it's common to hear
people exclaiming just how muscular
sprinters look despite not lifting lots
of weight and these are the reasons why
of course this is great for burning
calories and training the cardiovascular
system the heart continues to work hard
even as we walk back because it needs to
now calm back down that means you're
getting a better cardio workout in less
time I mean this is a short amount of
exercise it's not going to burn drastic
calories let's not get ahead of
ourselves but sprinting is excellent for
body recomposition and it certainly
doesn't hurt to give it a go a few times
a week on top of all of that sprinting
and running are important skills that
are worth building for anyone you can
film yourself watch it back and work on
your form over
time and you'll be increasing
explosiveness that will transfer to
pretty much all athletic Endeavors and
it will Compound on top of the earlier
jump rope and if you're doing this on
grass you'll once again be benefiting
from all that extra stabilization
toughening up your ankles and feet to
handle uneven terrain reducing your
likelihood of future injury and becoming
much faster over time what I will say
though and this is important is to be
very careful with this check the ground
where you're going to be running first
make sure there's no rabbit holes or
junk littered there Big Sticks also
build up to this extremely slowly I've
been doing this sort of stupid stuff for
years but if you twist an ankle running
at full speed it's going to be very
painful and you're going to be out of
leg training for months or maybe even a
year so be smart just like you wouldn't
try and bench 150 kg on your first day
don't go and Sprint on an uneven terrain
at full speed either unless you've been
doing this kind of thing unless you're
very confident just start with a
slightly slower run it's no biggie it's
also generally high impact so if you're
not able to train this way other easier
options include jogging running a little
slower high knees lunge walks or
weighted carries but if you can Sprint
Sprint okay now to cool down and make
sure that all your blood goes back to
where it's meant to be we're just going
to walk for a few minutes you don't need
to see me do that I mean you know how to
walk if you like this workout and you
want to give it a try I recommend easing
into it with some of the easier options
I recommended aim for two to three times
per week and then add in the more
difficult exercises as you become more
confident that should be plenty to start
getting some results and if you need
more instruction don't forget you can
try out super functional training 2.0 in
the link down below let me know what you
think about the workout and this kind of
content guys thank you so much for
watching and bye for now